le rouleur ou où l'air est un gros
tambour frappé à demain
traditionnellement fabriqués dans un
tronc est vide et hautbois variable d'au
moins 70 cm de long et 50 cm de diamètre
il est souvent conçus aujourd'hui avec
une barrique ou un tonneau dont on a
détruit les deux extrémités
le plus souvent la peau et de boeuf le
rouleur fournit le son le plus grave est
la base rythmique la plus importante
dans le maloya le percussionniste joue
du rouleur en s'asseyant sur le tonneau
ce qui lui permet de modifier la tension
est donc le timbre en se servant de l'un
de ses pieds
nous sommes à sainte-clotilde dans
l'arrière-cour de ce petit bâtiment
stéphane m'bia sa fabrique d'instruments
traditionnels réunionnais milliers vous
êtes peut voir la nena des troncs de
voile et là c'est la matière première on
travaillait le voir dans ses locaux au
rez-de-chaussée commandes étage les
pièces sont ronds clean instruments
divers et voilà ces voix jacques jeu
l'exécution des missions africaines des
qustions kubel cesson d'afrique
ça s'est calmé la réunion l'histoire
dépôt mais sa spécialité reste la
fabrication de couleurs et de djembé il
nous raconte son histoire avec la
musique
une vraie histoire d'amour m'a reconnu
le maloya jouer maloya avec un monsieur
des camélias méchas les ruelles
voilà voilà comment c'est clean et puis
doucement comme la rencontre madame à la
pâture conservatoire mala format - le
déclic simon madame bon madame et cauris
musiciennes du commun comme un maître
mot avec elle du coup 8e la musique donc
là lâche le frère de madame fait la
musique donc mais 1000 m
me hamel dans le mièvre la musique donc
mal à alès ça m'a attirée par la musique
mais de l'unss entreprendre dans la
fabrication d'instruments traditionnels
le pain n'est pas si évident la
difficulté pour le jeune homme a trouvé
des instruments de qualité sur le marché
la lancer dans cette aventure
aujourd'hui stéphane vie de son activité
mais insiste sur le fait que pour durer
il faut faire de la qualité mais aussi
innover rejoignez médias ne touche du
bois mais arrivent à vivre de sa part
pour moi me voudrait mais nous arrive de
se battre
de confiance faut connaître travail les
gens en ce moment là besoin de qualité
surtout la qualité ne vais pas au fait
un instrument plus fait un instrument
il propose à ses clients des instruments
sur mesure et 26 car la réunion haut
niveau écrit un message d une il veut
que tels ils veulent travailler avec moi
jacques le client il investit investi
dans quelque chose de solide est quelque
chose que les uniques haussier à la fois
et au delà de vivre de sa passion et de
son métier
la fierté du jeune percussionniste
réside surtout dans le fait de pratiquer
un métier qui se perd et de transmettre
un patrimoine ancestral aux générations
futures pour l'électricien a beaucoup
d'électricien et tandis que les gens qui
est qui qui qui fait les tango qui
fabriquait temps loi elle après beaucoup
donc la fierté c'est de dire que mr eh
ben il est fait quelque chose qui la
fait un magnifique et demain matin 1,8
me les mines voudrait que demain matin
mais même s'ils roulaient tyrolien que
le créole in a un petit goût là sont
quasi les connais la différence entre un
roulé au djembé nou néna une histoire
voilà mais pas forcément écrit dans le
livre mais tradition orale les lie ps6
de manière dure longtemps et 45e que le
baume timar mois qui arrivent des
lyonnais ils voient l envie aussi